the sun is shining the birds are singing
it looks like the start of another
lovely day
you're a walking happily in the park
when a term a passing stranger has
expelled mucus and saliva from their
mouth and nose you can feel the droplets
of moisture land on your skin but what
you can't feel are the thousands or even
millions of microscopic germs that have
covertly traveled through the air and
onto your clothing hands and face as
gross as this scenario sounds it's
actually very common for our bodies to
be exposed to disease-causing germs and
most of the time it's not nearly as
obvious germs are found on almost every
surface we come into contact with when
we talk about germs
we're actually referring to many
different kinds of microscopic organisms
including bacteria fungi protozoa and
viruses but what are germs all have in
common is the ability to interact with
our bodies and change how we feel in
function scientists who study infectious
diseases have wonder for decades why it
is that some of these germs are
relatively harmless
while others cause devastating effects
and can sometimes be fatal
we still haven't solved the entire
puzzle but what we do know is that the
harmfulness or virulence of a germ is a
result of evolution how can it be that
the same evolutionary process can
produce germs that cause very different
levels of harm the answer starts to
become clear if we think about a germs
mode of transmission which is the
strategy it uses to get from one host to
the next a common mode of transmission
occurs through the air like the sneeze
you just witnessed and one germ that
uses this method is the rhinovirus
which replicates in our upper Airways
and is responsible for up to half of all
common colds now imagine that after the
sneeze one of three hypothetical
varieties of rhinovirus let's call them
too much too little and just right has
been lucky enough to land on you these
viruses are hardwired to replicate but
because of genetic differences they will
do so at different rates too much
multiply is very often making it very
successful in the short run
however this success comes at a cost to
you the host a quickly replicating virus
can cause more damage to your body
making cold symptoms more severe if
you're too sick to leave your home you
don't give the virus any opportunities
to jump to a new host and if the disease
should kill you the viruses own life
cycle will end along with yours too
little on the other hand multiplies
rarely and causes you little harm in the
process although this leaves you healthy
enough to interact with other potential
hosts the lack of symptoms means you may
not sneeze at all or if you do there may
be too few viruses in your mucus to
infect anyone else meanwhile just-right
has been replicating quickly enough to
ensure that you're carrying sufficient
amounts of the virus to spread but not
so often that you are too sick to get
out of bed and in the end it's the one
that will be most successful at
transmitting itself to new hosts and
giving rise to the next generation this
describes what scientists call trade-off
hypothesis first developed in the early
1980s it predicts that germs will evolve
to maximize their overall success by
achieving a balance between replicating
within a host which causes virulence and
transmission to a new host in the case
of the Rhino virus the hypothesis
predicts that it's evolution will favour
less virulent forms because it relies on
close contact to get to its next victim
for the Rhino virus a mobile host is a
good host and indeed that is what we see
while most people experience a runny
nose coughing and sneezing the common
cold is generally mild and only lasts
about a week it would be great if the
story ended there but germs use many
other modes of transmission for example
the malaria parasite Plasmodium is
transmitted by mosquitoes unlike the
Rhino virus it doesn't need us to be up
and about and may even benefit from
harming us since a sick and immobile
person is easier for mosquitoes to bite
we would expect germs that depend less
on host mobility like those transmitted
by insects water or food to cause more
severe symptoms so what can we do to
reduce the harmfulness of infectious
diseases evolutionary biologist dr. Paul
Ewald has suggested that we can actually
direct their evolution through simple
disease control methods by mosquito
proofing houses establishing clean water
systems or staying home when we get a
cold we can obstruct the transmission
strategies of harm
germs while creating a greater
dependence on host mobility so while
traditional methods of trying to
eradicate germs may only breed stronger
ones in the long run this innovative
approach of encouraging them to evolve
milder forms could be a win-win
situation well for the most part